I want to look at a few clips from an
event that took place in South Carolina
over the weekend the event is called
Vision 24 the national conservative
Forum a couple of interesting speakers
there we will get to Nikki Haley who
spoke there but I want to start with
Tulsi gabber now Tulsi gabbard is
someone who started as a democratic
congresswoman who ran for president back
in 2020
extraordinarily transparent grifter
which unfortunately summoned my audience
and in concern in left-wing media fell
for Hook Line and Sinker but she is no
longer a Democrat and she now promotes
anti-vax and she promotes all sorts of
crazy stuff the grift is up except it
kind of has only just started because
everything Tulsi is doing is her most
direct path to making money and I'll
explain that in a moment but Tulsi
gabbard spoke at this conservative forum
and I have to tell you she is truly a
sick person in this first clip Tulsi
revives the completely debunked notion
of Democrats supporting abortion after
birth or as you and I might call it the
killing of children this is of course
not true it's been widely debunked let's
look at what tools see now has the
audacity to say remember this was the
last real liberal according to someone
on the left
you celebrate
I couldn't believe it when I saw in this
last state of the union speech how many
members of Congress are walking around
with a big abortion pin on their suit
jacket right incredible that they feel a
need to support that to show that they
support
women's rights to make medical decisions
in the context of a supreme court and a
Republican party that is hell-bent on
attacking that right but shocking that
Democrats would show that hey we support
women's rights
not just advocating for but celebrating
abortion on depend on demand without
exception
all the way up until birth or even after
birth normalizing and fantasy we've seen
this in places like New York and in
other states what so this this is
straight up untrue so let's break it
down into two parts until birth and then
after birth
even until birth is very deceptive and
I'll explain to you why
so-called late-term abortions right the
kind that would need to be approved
under special circumstances in many
state laws are extraordinarily rare
Republicans continue doing this thing
where they love to pretend you can be
you know 37 and a half weeks pregnant
and show up and say you know what I'd
like to end the pregnancy OB gyns have
extensively testified under oath that it
doesn't happen and that if it did it
wouldn't be something that 99.9 of OB
gyns would even do these are extremely
rare situations that in almost every
case relate to extreme circumstances
things that are discovered about the
health of the fetus or the or the health
of the mother it is insanely rare under
one percent of abortions are performed
after 21 weeks never mind 32 weeks 34
weeks the way these people want to talk
about insanely rare and the idea of ah
you know what my due dates next week I
think I want an abortion
almost imaginary beyond that this entire
after birth abortion I mean just it's
it's completely fat fabricated and Tulsi
of all people is now going with it just
disgusting person truly disgusting
person that she has debased herself in
this way then she does the elitist cabal
stuff she's buying into that as well
when you look at the Democratic party of
today it is
party that is controlled by this elitist
cabal of War mongers
that has been and continues to be
led by the queen of warmongers herself
Hillary Clinton right
it's true
the Applause delayed there people are
like wait Hillary the warmonger what
and who
who their policies they are driven by
this uh motivation of cowardly wokeness
they are such cowards
and bloodthirsty warmongers but they're
they're cowards and their work it
doesn't make sense now why is she doing
this
I hate to to say that it's this simple
but I I believe this is this is probably
it this is how she maximizes her income
okay she's got a podcast and she gets
paid to speak and she's a Fox News
contributor Tulsi gabbard made I believe
at the time that she was a member of
Congress I think the salary was 174 000
a year
she did this run for president total
failure she got what one percent of the
vote zero I don't even she was polling
one or two percent and I don't know that
anybody voted for her totally failed not
remotely uh a progressive
um platform in reality so now she's done
the thing where she becomes right wing
the left left me the Democratic party
has failed me
so that's an appealing product and
that's what it is it's a product the
former left Winger who by the way wasn't
really left so she starts doing speaking
gigs for what you know based on her
notoriety
this is a very rough guess but she could
probably get between 12 and 25
000 per speaking Gig if she has a good
speaking agent
um the podcast you know it doesn't seem
like a huge podcast but it might net her
like low six figures and then she's a
Fox News contributor probably also like
a low six-figure deal so that's the
grift she probably these are super rough
estimates she's probably making half a
million bucks a year it might be 250 it
might be 600 or 650. yeah it's something
this is the most lucrative way to
productize herself to turn herself into
the commodity of the former Democrat
who's willing to go and talk about how
vaccines are bad and trans is bad and
abortion is bad and on and on and on if
she remains a Democrat no one listens to
her podcast it's not a good podcast if
she's a Democrat she doesn't get any of
these speaking gigs because the right is
much more interested in funding oh the 4
former Democrat and if she's a Democrat
she almost certainly doesn't get uh the
Fox News contributorship and by when I
say if she's a Democrat I mean if she
continues to be at least claiming to be
on the left she could have you know
nominally remained a Democrat and done
basically the same stuff so it's it's
the grift and this is what tool C is
doing and to the extent that she's like
what's best for myself personally I get
it it's just pretty disgustingly overtly
agrift and this is where we end up uh
tools he's saying Democrats want to do
abortion after birth